all right who's on my team I'm going on
I am I'm going on the upper level keep
an eye out I'll look at the bottom gonna
be there are so many [ __ ] chairs
you're just be kidding me
yeah I mean if one is standing out is I
have one stands out I mean unless they
manage to put one of the Chi not even in
a library yeah
I'm not even gonna touch the chairs you
can Center it yeah don't don't raise
your voice guys what them alright I'll
keep that in mind what's with the shirt
you're not allowed to fire guns well was
that library oh you go do it's like a
little staircase you go down yeah wait
how do you know because I can see you oh
yeah yeah
I mean that would be a good hose it
moving us your book already underway uh
you're right
drew you're right it's been the
bookshelves back there I saw it
somewhere find there it just going
around the other side manners you can't
shoot him from this range lunch and
grenade I don't know I'm legal uh yeah
no you're good you're good okay
I mean a little library you may read
some things those things don't have to
be limited to books they could also be
the newspaper uh-huh yeah yeah George
the newspaper oh oh I did get it if you
wanted if you wanted some clarification
I was on the fence but now you guys
really drove it home yeah yeah and it's
off the scent man there is wow I didn't
even see hey Marv like what uh London
hole or something team what go go team
go
yeah oh okay I'll be exactly that Wow
don't do that it might not be good for
you got uh wait what do we don't do fine
oh sure oh [ __ ] okay you know what what
all right okay what happens oh god yeah
I can't wait to fight I see where you
are and where you are in you know what
I'm gonna go skate around still watch
I'm not gonna say anything I'm just
gonna rent watch it's all good it's all
good in this
ready go ready to go oh you have the
ability to do this tell you what know
what someone's a block just running
around with a bottle yeah
you'll bottle trick huh nice I can't
like an elevated you this Oh George you
stay up and I'll stay down cuz I got
enough to get down that's our sack gotta
get up to get down um okay I will look
for a bottle George haha you ghost me
man I'm trying to mmm yeah so we got
Adam yeah you got away from me once but
then I thought maybe I'm gonna resume
right now loser
yes don't think doofus is the right word
max I think I'm just trying to think of
different insults that I haven't used
for you yeah miss I don't think I've
used doofus or ignoramus big morenas I
don't know about that one big more anus
yeah oh look at this
I was keeping away from the bird's-eye
view
yo Marky Mark check out where I'm at and
let me know if you think this like what
we think uh-oh
that's gonna be tough to find huh now
say no more okay
yeah about it okay you can keep talking
so I can tell you in submarine that spot
is it's just impeccable in its design
and only genius-level intellect could
have possibly come up with that I like
it when you say things like this to me
yes
Wow flatter him some more why don't you
okay I will yeah we're gonna get a room
to ourselves flatter each other if
anyone else could have thought of
something like that surely their brains
would have exploded cuz they couldn't
have handled it what you what what what
so so he heard of Leonardo da Vinci
Oh for prop hun Leonardo provincial over
here just oh oh please no no prop in G
just call me that you take your steam
name to that yeah well I figured you
know I'm in a place of intellect of
uh-huh yes thought I had to raise my
game oh yeah
a level of Leonardo da Vinci which is my
new title so exactly I'm a sonic
screwdriver dr. Kimsey no you she's not
a chair I'm not a chair certain I gotta
test it regardless oh yeah yeah okay go
go for the chairs yeah solid just
remember we tried to help ya not a
traffic cone either not a trash can
you'll never find Leonardo prep pinchy
ever I real hard though damn it I was so
close yeah vinod did you find him I
thought maybe he was just in a bunch of
scattered books and nothing was on
anyway
but when he said you were close he means
you were way off and looked like a total
[ __ ]
thanks mug you and I should just go here
if they don't even know for the Union
are you in a place that isn't even like
accessible oh yeah totally
that's just silly you're being real
silly you could walk right up to it no
jumping room it's totally fair yeah it's
absolutely fair mm-hmm three seconds oh
you didn't get it oh that's sad
watching things from above got a real go
someone's being real dumb right now how
dice are they just put down the security
stairs uh-huh so there's only one door
they can exit from there right yeah it's
only one all right I'm watching it so so
why don't you go down why don't you go
down to the bottom part you got it with
the security doors
exits you got it and I'll stay here you
got it all right CA now we move anything
you see anything
I don't sold my god has he not oh my god
does he nothing how I didn't how did I
have like guys anything
Omega tedious yeah
Kevin if he hasn't uh with couldn't just
open or and we've done no no I'm just as
until believably confused right now what
did he do I don't know gotta be there
he's got it I didn't I saw nothing
knocking sheets what scrap my life right
now are you sick I don't know
go back go back wait no I'm gonna go
back there's gotta be some there do you
know it's gotta be something our seas
are moving those are what you two just
confuse them
I enjoyed the long shot oh the [ __ ] we
got 50 seconds to figure this out here
oh god I'm alone you made me alone in it
now one looks like a magic tables in
those chairs like what about him is your
table
what no I blew those up start at the
very beginning
I'm peep-bo them were looking at me they
were just really really like okay so
what we're looking at the beginning uh
well we spawned over here and wheel
ain't going to file this round under
files oh yeah I was using you to try to
get them to look at her oh this is a bad
idea is a bad idea
I'm gonna assume because a bad idea is
this this is about oh yeah well you're
doing shut up
I'm uh just let them eat great we're
gonna now now you turned it around I
like it you got it yeah thank you oh I
know what happened huh okay I know I
always wanna look at the book someone
loved it hey give me a look so I want to
read something on the library all right
now see my spot and know how Zen I am
with the world around me
how perfect this place yeah uh-huh yeah
I gonna tell you what you do hidden I
could possibly be I couldn't be more
perfect
mm-hmm in all honesty you're perfect
time yes just the way you are yeah I
know
did you officially check upstairs
thoroughly mmm some maze I mean you're
downstairs or uh Jordan
does it out of the ordinary
what are you so can I know what do you
mean it doesn't make any sense sometimes
when you're filing yeah
thirsty we live over here hey it's
something like a normal uh um you know
yes Pablo's entire kappa yeah going 70
bombs it didn't hurt oh he's got how are
you don't bring out a cone fell down so
that's eight got him you got him right
now you can you can sniff out my light I
just look around here alright see I
don't know I must I don't know about
this spot I agree with you Jordan I also
don't know right there
no no no no I put that I put that book
there you a sincere deceptive is working
son of a [ __ ] you made me lose my perch
sorry so I upstairs perch I don't know
why max keeps dancing on top of the
computers that's me that's me I'm
dancing why I ain't dancing mark lines
just sometimes I feel like dancing jinks
feelings yeah that's good should I check
on the chairs is that what I need oh
yeah check all the chairs any reaction
alright oh oh
cuz the phone was down I forgot about
that party save me you see me no I don't
where are you no I'm not I don't say oh
you're nearly okay what do you mean
saved you okay alright okay you go
dumped a maneuver good
Oh God oh man
listen I'll sell Jordan out just gave me
other prop ones what I did last room
okay I got no sin I have I have
information officers okay that sounds
good okay I guess I can still get it off
your hard drive I'm not I'm not the
thing I think you think I am
no I know it's okay I can clearly see
what your orange i misclicked I used my
grenade so sir oh no all right well I
guess I still got mine okay yes yes he
is he able to be seen not did he's he's
he's able to be seen no no no I'm gonna
imagine orden you would never cheat ever
mmm not only Stax's not on his girl
phone well not on it right by the
computer that scene has a keyboard all
right
in seven seconds
they cried
quick